au parc de thoiry pendant le confinement
plusieurs bébés ont vu le jour comme les
makis cattas une espèce de lémurien un
couple de coyote est arrivé également le
27 avril
fermé depuis quasiment six mois le parc
de plus de 75 hectares à retrouver ce
visiteur en jouer moi j'ai vu des
concours ou péter rauque et des bébés
kangourous dans la poche des mamans
aussi des lionnes des murs des impôts le
crocodile est aussi et l'autruche on en
a profité c'est la réouverture et puis
avec les enfants le mercredi c'est
toujours il avait hâte de pouvoir
revenir
on a l'habitude de venir donc voilà on
avait hâte louis adore adorent aller au
zoo on a le pass annuel à thoiry donc du
coup du coup on y va et grand plaisir
oui depuis le 19 mai ces six oursons
seront aussi connaissance avec le public
ils sont nés cet hiver il passe deux
mois accroché à la main même de sa maman
dans sa tanière
et il ressort dans le monde réel quand
il est capable de d'être être autonome
sur la partie froid et autres et
protection avec sa maman avec la crise
sanitaire le port du masque est toujours
obligatoire dans tout le parc et le zoo
au safari de thoiry a maintenu sa sharks
au king size ça fait un nom qu'on vit
avec un protocole sanitaire de 19 pages
où toute la restauration est en vente à
emporter sur les tables extérieures tout
à parti qu'est s'est fait
majoritairement sur internet évidemment
on comprend aussi les gens qui viennent
sur place mais on met en vente les
billets en ligne un billet daté jour par
jour en fonction des jo je combats et si
l'on veut poursuivre l'aventuré plus
longtemps qu'une journée le zoo de
thoiry propose une nuit dans l'une des
vingt tanière une nouveauté 2021 pour
dormir avec les ours les loups et les
bisous